they can fly travel at the speed of
light and command the currents they
don't need another way to get around
or do they
I don't recognize this well we don't
have to recognize it we just have to
save him shall we
today we got something very exciting
extremely exclusive it's been built
especially for this show the brand new
e-class convertible from mercedes-benz
this car is a prototype and we have it
here exclusively
in order for us to be able to relate to
this movie we need to have things that
we are all familiar with and who's not
familiar with Mercedes right so I think
it was a good choice I was very
depressed
the car Diana drives is very elegant and
not too flashy very chic and practical
[Music]
we get to keep the car and left driving
hey what are your superpowers again I'm
rich
[Music]
[Applause]
Bruce Wayne has no shortage of ways to
get around these up is pretty cool
civilian Mercedes car that we're showing
in the movie which is pretty awesome
Zack Snyder the director of the film saw
the vision GT which was an electronic
remote control concept car that was
designed by Mercedes for the video game
Gran Turismo and because it was just
designed for the game it was never a
real functioning vehicle and because Ben
Affleck who plays Bruce Wayne and Batman
is six for in order to make it work for
our needs so they expanded the car about
10% when they built it out this is
really a dream project for any designer
to be able to do something like this
because we were responsible for the
original concept that has now been
translated into this movie car so the
original show car didn't have an
interior so we had to basically create
the natural physical interior
[Music]
this has got to be one of if not the
coolest Bruce Wayne related vehicles
they're not even a wheel you can't even
call they're reinventing the wheel all
right like it let's film it let me shoot
Rockets right to put Bruce Wayne behind
the wheel of an experimental prototype
vehicle like the V GT it's a great fit I
think they made it also just specially
to look awesome a lot of people want to
take pictures of the car
an almost support to say this huge
support from Sadie's both widths of
background cars and this projects on the
whole and having Bruce Wayne's car I've
never seen a car like this associated
with any character and any movie so it
is really unique and super exciting
[Music]
you
you